[Música]
[Aplausos]
este negro está autorizado a entrar aqui
essa foi a pergunta que houve em 1993
quando tinha 16 anos no auge do período
da autoafirmação de um adolescente da
tia da minha primeira namorada uma
menina branca quando entra na sua casa
pela primeira vez eu lembro que fiquei
sem o que dizer de meia volta e voltei
pra casa
não tive coragem de contar para minha
mãe duas semanas depois eu contei para o
meu pai que sabiamente me fez duas
perguntas
meu pai me chamava de negão
eu acho que essa menina gosta de tia ela
está contigo porque ela gosta de ti ou
ela está contigo que afrontar a família
dela eu disse eu não sei pai eo meu pai
me disse assim essa resposta em ti
porque se eu te disser o que tem que
fazer
e tu não fizer eu vou acabar brigando
contínuo e além de seu pai
eu sou teu amigo e eu não quero que isso
aconteça eu guardo com muito carinho as
palavras que meu pai me disse naquele
momento e dali eu consegui entender como
funciona a cultura do racismo eo quanto
ela está entranhada na nossa sociedade
eu lembro que ela dividiu essas
histórias com ninguém na escola não
virar motivo de chacota já que é o único
negro na minha turma e as piadas
racistas eram bem comuns como não vai
fazer a entrada em na saída comdec negra
gente quando está no banheiro não vai
fazer coisa de preto mas tudo é preto é
um negro de alma branca é o nosso
negresco bastava olhar para o lado e me
lembrar todo o
tempo de que aquele não era um espaço
aberto para pessoas negras como eu mas o
esporte me deu pertencimento
eu era aceito eu era bom e de certa
maneira com todas as dificuldades
eu era convidado a estar com eles
eu comecei a jogar futebol de salão em
e eu lembro que nós iríamos jogar contra
uma equipe praticamente imbatível e na
conversa de vestiário o treinador
perguntou o que nós podemos fazer para
ganhar desse time de um silêncio no
vestiário
levantei minha mão e arrisquei vamos
fazer tudo que a gente treinou durante a
semana ele em tom de deboche
olhou para o diretor e disse tu vê em
tão inteligente tão esperto só tem um
defeito com dez anos eu passei por essa
situação na exposição do racismo
estrutural
eu fiquei com aquilo em gado porque eu
sabia que ele tava falando na cor da
minha pele
mas a rotina dos treinos
era o que me alimentava me fortalecia e
as armadilhas do adolescente eu consegui
escapar
eu era o único aluno negro do 3º ano da
escola
a história de ser o único nos espaços
ocupados por pessoas brancas
sempre sempre me acompanharam na
faculdade
o time de basquete do time do colégio na
arbitragem
ao entrar para o mundo profissional como
árbitro da federação gaúcha de futebol
eu sabia que a onde eu estivesse racismo
estaria comigo estaria acompanhado
em 2006 eu fui atacado 2005 e 2006 e foi
atacado violentamente duas vezes e numa
em um desses ataques é um jogador que
cometeu o racismo
saiu um peso a gente foi até o palácio
da polícia
e fizemos a ocorrência é de 2006 e 2014
eu já a conhecia mais em campo porque
vários outros casos acontecendo na noite
do dia 5 de março de 2014
não foi diferente na serra gaúcha
acontece no vestiário sozinho enquanto
os meus colegas aquecer no campo nos
colegas brancos para evitar os
xingamentos racistas que normalmente
vinham das arquibancadas como negro sujo
volta da áfrica à escória macaco e uma
que me matava muito matar negro não é
crime a adubar a terra e não foi
diferente daquela noite eu fui xingado
ao sair do vestiário para dar o início
da partida
no retorno para o intervalo da partida
na saída do vestiário para o reinício do
jogo e no final da partida
sempre acompanhado dos policiais que não
quiseram absolutamente nada eu passei
por duas situações de crime uma racismo
que faz parte está na constituição desde
1988 como um crime empresa que este
interesse que tiver eu ir na frança' véu
e de injúrias raciais que estão no
código penal
e mais uma vez me sentir sozinho
o pior estava por vir
quando eu fui pegar o meu carro que
estava no estacionamento único exclusivo
de acesso à arbitragem
eu me deparei com um veículo amassado
com as portas às portas a pontapé
cascas de banana sobre a lataria e
quando fui da partida do veículo caíram
duas bananas do cano de escapamento
ali eu fiquei com muita raiva ea minha
vontade era voltar lá e quebrar tudo mas
não o fez porque eu sabia que algo em
mim tinha que ser racional e fazer o que
eles imaginariam que eu não iria fazer
denunciar e foi o que eu fiz
cheguei em casa por volta das 3 horas da
manhã
adrenalina a mil um com muita raiva
não acordei minha esposa foi no quarto
do meu filho inúmeras vezes e muito das
minhas ações têm a ver com o futuro do
meu filho dos meus filhos
na época só tinha um cara legal eu não
queria que vai acontecer com eles eu não
quero que aquilo ali aconteça com eles
o fato veio à tona e o presidente da
federação gaúcha de futebol me ligou
porque tu não me ligou a resolver essa
situação está expondo o clube está
expondo o estado está expondo a
competição e eu perguntei eu vocês estão
acostumados com isso
eu pago o seu carro mas eu tô pedindo
dinheiro te pedindo respeito é bom
sabes que isso pode causar problema está
colocando a sua carreira em risco
eu disse eu vou pagar esse preço
quem deveria ter me apoiado mais uma vez
me deixou sozinho
tempos depois
na audiência o advogado de defesa disse
masaru botar bananas no v
chamar um negro de macaco não é ofensivo
não é um crime mas se deparar com um
veículo apa com as portas amassadas a
pontapés isso sim é doloroso porque o
brasileiro é apaixonado por carros
todos riram lá dentro isso é racismo
estrutural que constitui as relações em
seu padrão de normalidade é o
constrangimento na esfera econômica
política é um mecanismo que se manifesta
em normas práticas e comportamentos
discriminatórios adotados um dia a dia
que garantem exclusão seletiva de
pessoas apenas por serem quem são e mais
uma vez vamos sentir sozinha eu apitei
até a final do campeonato de 2014
inclusive foi eleito pela quarta vez
consecutiva como o melhor árbitro do
campeonato gaúcho
segundo o ibge a 54% da população é
composta de pessoas pardas negras e
mestiças quantas pessoas negras pardas e
mestiças ocupam cargos importantes no
esporte sem que sejam os atletas desde a
minha saída em 2014
nenhum árbitro negro mais apitou
campeonato gaúcho da primeira divisão
até quando vamos aceitar e permitir a
normalização do absurdo eu acredito que
um dos maiores desafios e dificuldades
se tenha na vida é educar um filho e
prepará lo emocionalmente
psicologicamente para enfrentar o mundo
eu tive uma educação muito severa do meu
pai meu pai sempre dizia pra mim para os
meus irmãos que nós como negros
deveríamos ser duas três vezes melhor
que mesmo assim nós seríamos colocados
em dúvida
e hoje eu entendo por quê
o meu erro é sempre potencializado
então eu não posso errar não tem o
direito de errar porque sempre pesa a
questão da minha cor
este negro não está capacitado para
ocupar determinado espaço
eu sou muito feliz pela educação
transparente e sincera que eu tive dos
meus pais minha mãe professora meu pai
engenheiro sempre nos trataram - deram o
caminho correto
fizeram de tudo para que eu e os meus
três irmãos concluir temos um ensino
superior e concluímos uma família de
negros quatro filhos com curso superior
e isso é uma realidade para o brasil tão
racista trabalhar no maior grupo de
comunicação do estado também é uma
vitória ter sido eleito cinco vezes como
melhor árbitro do campeonato gaúcho ter
sido aspirante à fifa palestrar sobre
racismo sobre as experiências como
árbitro e cada experiência de vida ao
longo do tempo
mas tudo isso tem um preço porque não
têm como lidar com o racismo sem que
afete a saúde mental
eu já fui ver inúmeras vezes de
frequentar determinados espaços para não
me sentir o único e tento vencer isso
pároco para acompanhar os meus filhos
saber que eles estão na construção do
mundo deles e eu não quero deixá los
sozinhos um preto sempre preterido nos
contextos sociais ele nunca protagonista
ele sempre é um coadjuvante
a lealdade e amizade do papo que eu tive
com o meu pai entre outros tantos
eu tento levar para os meus filhos
o único que num universo de 300 crianças
eles são as únicas crianças negras na
escola onde frequentam repetindo tudo
que aconteceu comigo e com a minha
esposa mas a necessidade de oportunizar
los oportunizadas as condições melhores
a gente acaba caindo num ambiente
extremamente branca é cdu onde a gente
esquece das nossas origens esquece da
nossa história e o que dita as normas
são os privilégios herdados de uma
história
o márcio de 16 anos não tinha resposta
para aquela senhora que perguntou este
negro precisa de autorização para entrar
aqui eu digo que não
este negro não precisam de autorização
para entrar aqui os meus filhos não
precisam da organização de atlanta em
lugar nenhum
o meu filho miguel entra nas casas de
vocês através das campanhas
publicitárias que faz a minha filha
quando eu digo que ela é linda ela
responde com a segurança que eu demorei
muito na vida pra te porque ela sabe que
ela é linda e ela disse eu sei papai
a minha esposa que sempre esteve comigo
nesses 23 anos e me ajudou muito na
construção do homem que eu sou hoje e me
valorizar através da negritude da
representação que eu tenho junto ao meu
povo não só o meu povo
mas no geral a falar sobre um assunto
que é tão mascarado que é tão velado e
ao mesmo tempo explicito este negro não
precisa da autorização de ninguém nenhum
negro precisa
obrigado
[Aplausos]